we're gonna make a short statement here
I've had this courthouse and later on we
will track my try to be available to the
press
gentleman we'll start here since 2010
we've warned that join Assange would
face prosecution and extradition to the
United States for his publishing
activities with WikiLeaks unfortunately
today we've been proven right mr.
Assange was arrested this morning at
about 10 o'clock and the Ecuadorian
embassy after the Ambassador formally
notified me please
asylum revoked and he was arrested by
British police with today received a
warrant and a provisional extradition
request from the United States alleging
that he has committed had conspired with
Chelsea Manning in relation to the
materials that were published by
WikiLeaks
in 2010
this sets a dangerous precedent for all
media organizations and journalists in
Europe and elsewhere around the world
this precedent means that any journalist
can be extradited for prosecution in the
United States for having published
truthful information about the United
States I've just been with mr. Assange
in the police cells he wants to thank
all of his supporters for their ongoing
support and he said I told you so
[Music]
well only thing to add to this is the
fact that this is a dark day for
journalism as soon as Jennifer said the
sets a president we don't want this to
go forward this has to has to be averted
the UK government needs to make a full
assurance that of journalists will never
be extradited to the United States for
publishing activity this pertains to
publishing work nine years ago
publishing of documents of videos of
killing of innocent civilians exposure
of war crimes this is journalism
it's called conspiracy its conspiracy to
commit journalism so this has to end and
we urge everybody to support Julian
Assange into fighting his extradition
thank you Oh at least what legal avenues
are available to you
prevent his extradition we will be
contesting and fighting extradition
we've requested that he now set gets
medical treatment he's been refused
medical treatment for the past seven and
a half years since seven years since
being inside the embassy we will be
fighting extradition and he'll be
brought before the court again within
the next month
we're not going to be taking anymore
questions today thank you very much you
are asking about the the elements in the
extradition request it is quite obvious
that the US authorities have picked just
one element of what they have been
working on for a long time
including the Espionage Act acts that
are have decades in prison there is no
assurance that there would not be
additional charges when he is on US soil
and I think and I believe that this was
an angle in the approach to increase the
likelihood of him being extradited